[Music]
welcome to the Disney fairy land of
Pixie Hollow where you'll meet ten
palm-sized fairies with amazing
superpowers stay tuned to see what these
fairies look like in real life and wait
until you see who Tinker Bell was
actually based on don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to our Channel
now join us as we look at ten Disney
Fairies in real life Rosetta
did you know that the southern accented
Rosetta was one of the first fairies to
arrive at the Pixie Hollow
she's a garden talent fairy and she's
known to be extremely gentle Rosetta
does have a sassy side to her and she
can sometimes act like a little bit of a
princess
remember when she stated that she isn't
really the type to walk in mud to get to
the other side and Vidia pointed out
she's supposed to be a garden fairy
Rosetta just called it ironic but she
does have some pretty awesome powers and
can easily control the plant life and
the earth looks wise Rosetta is a
typical girly girl she's very into
fashion and always makes sure she looks
good no matter what her makeup is always
on point and her fashionable dresses are
accompanied by the red shoulder-length
hair she sounds like an awesome
character to cosplay but no one can do
Rosetta better than the actual Disney
Land version of Rosetta she looks just
as sweet and almost identical to the
cartoon fairy Rosetta was voiced by
kristin chenoweth in the early days and
later by Megan Hilty the garden fairy is
featured in almost every Tinkerbell
movie and she always tends to steal the
spotlight what else would you expect
from a cute little fairy with a southern
accent fairy Gary fairy Gary is a Disney
character you won't know unless you saw
the 2009 movie Tinker Bell and the lost
treasure fairy Gary is quite an
interesting character probably known
only to hard-core Disney fans his job is
to oversee dust talent fairies kind of
like being a talent manager in real life
he's big muscular with a huge nose and
mustache that connects to his beard and
runs all the way up to his hair it seems
very strange that Disney would choose
him as one of the fairies but we're so
happy they did fairy Gary is one of the
most hilarious fairies out there and our
favorite moment was when he shouts
dust-keeper pride during Pixie Hollow
Games we scoured the Internet and found
this picture of a real-life fairy Gary
together with all of his favorite Disney
Fairies his outfit is pretty spot-on and
we love the elvish boots and his kilt
fairy Gary is voiced by Jeff Bennett who
also voiced Johnny Bravo Tong fo in Kung
Fu Panda TV series and plenty of other
cartoon characters if you ever wondered
how pixie dust works and who the best
Disney fairy is fairy Gary is your guy
to talk to
although we think the best Disney fairy
raw would belong to him Silver Mist and
now let's have a look at one of the
sweetest fairies out there this one is a
water talent fairy who's always
immensely positive incredibly friendly
and she always sees the glass is half
full and it's probably half full of
water she even has water fairy humor and
uses puns on a regular basis she's been
featured in almost all Disney fairy
movies including the fifth Tinkerbell
movie the pirate fairy
Silvermist is very small and can easily
fit in the palm of your hands which is
precisely why she is so sweet and gentle
she has bluish black hair a blue dress
and matching wings with matching sandals
she's one of the most caring fairies of
the bunch and her powers include molding
water into different shapes and forms we
have to say she can get pretty crafty
but that's not all she can also
communicate with sea creatures and of
course fly pretty impressive for a
palm-sized fairy right the human version
of Silver Mist can be found in the
actual Disney Land and she looks
incredible don't you think her dress and
her hair look identical just like we do
we bet she also wishes she could have
the power to fly Silver Mist is voiced
by Lucy Liu who also voiced Viper in
Kung Fu
and a-- and is also known for her roles
in Ally McBeal and Charlie's Angels Beck
Beck is mainly featured in books instead
of movies but that doesn't mean that she
is any less awesome
she's known as the animal talent fairy
and as you can guess she's very fond of
animals and believes in kindness toward
all creatures although she's mainly
featured in books that doesn't mean she
doesn't have a distinctive look that
sets her apart from other fairies Beck
looks like she could be a character from
Robin Hood her signature colors are
green and brown and her green hat makes
her resemble and elf Beck is also the
only fairy that tends to be around
mothered of the magical Duff that
brought back life to Pixie Hollow and
restored magic to Neverland but wait
until you see what this cosplayer looks
like as a real-life Beck this deviantART
users name is vash phonetic and Beck is
one of her favorite fairy characters
check out her awesome wings and her cool
outfit we hope she's used to animals
because if she's anything like Beck
she likes to spend more time with
animals than she does with humans in
fact Beck wants to become an animal
herself she can read their thoughts and
even speak the bird language if that's
not cool we're not sure what is brilla
just like Beck brilla only appears in
books but that doesn't mean she's not an
important character to the Disney fairy
stories Pirela was the only fairy that
didn't know her talent when she arrived
at the Pixie Hollow
although fairies never reveal their age
Briella looks like she could be one of
the youngest in the group
Briella has a very unusual power she
encourages clapping to prevent fairies
from dying you see fairies are created
by children once children laugh with
clapping prillie encourages other
children who still believe in fairies to
clap and keep her alive looks-wise
trilla has a lot going on with her
outfit which includes a large flower in
her hand her red curly hair has a mind
of its own and her cute lilac and green
dress are wonderful this cosplayer might
just be our favorite real-life Disney
fairy yet she looks absolutely identical
to Brella from her hair to her a may
hangout fit she is totally rocking her
cosplay look
although Brill is talent wasn't
discovered at first it was later found
that she doesn't only have one she can
also transport to the land of humans and
back to the fairyland with just a simple
blink we can imagine this can be quite
distracting if she's on a serious ferry
mission periwinkle
this frost talent fairy can only be
found in Tinker Bell's secret of the
wings movie Gliss is very energetic and
super friendly to anyone she needs
appearance wise periwinkle has pale skin
pink lips and a signature blue clothing
in fact she's one of the very few
fairies that wears trousers instead of a
short dress but we guess this is because
she's a frost fairy her powers include
control over ice and snow immunity from
the cold ice manipulation periwinkle has
another secret you won't know unless
you're a hardcore Disney fan she's
Tinker Bell's twin sister not only are
they very similar in their personalities
and mannerisms but they also share the
same wing pattern which is usually
unique to each fairy pretty cool huh
if you're looking to find a real-life
periwinkle you'll have to head to Disney
Land this performer looks like she has
the ice fairies look down to a tee and
we love it speaking of periwinkles did
you know that they're actually snails
and they have their own version of a
unique superpower
you see these snails even though they're
meant to be sea creatures can also
breathe air and live in both water and
land although we have to say we prefer
the fairies to the snails who wouldn't
want to have immunity to the cold fawn
so far we've had fun looking at several
real-life versions of the Disney Fairies
including periwinkle Rosetta Perla
Silver Mist BEC and fairy Gary let's
take a look at fawn she is yet another
animal talent fairy
but unlike back she does appear in the
movie versions of Disney Fairies fawn
has a very distinctive and unique look
to her although her hair might not have
periwinkles cool color it does have an
abnormally long braid which reminds us
of Rapunzel from tangled fawn is very
caring and selfless when it comes to
animals and of course she's a vegetarian
her brown and yellow outfit makes her
easy to blend in with the animal world
and she has some of the coolest powers
we have ever seen
just like Back fun can read animals
minds but she can also control and
communicate with any wildlife imagine
you could easily talk to your dog or
find out what it's thinking
although the real-life version of fun
doesn't have such cool powers she still
looks just like the animal talent fairy
doesn't her braids look amazing you can
find her in Disneyland Vaughan was once
voiced by America Ferrera and Jennifer
Goodwin and each of them is most known
for their individual roles in Ugly Betty
and once upon a time but it was Angela
Bartis who voiced farm the longest and
gave the character a recognizable voice
you have to admire fawn for her love of
animals as she doesn't discriminate
she gives eskimo kisses to squirrels and
she has no problem hanging out with
skunks
even though she probably shouldn't Vidia
videos powers might look like they're
not as cool as the rest of them but
she's the one bringing the breeze and
keeping the weather seasons in check
she's definitely one of the coolest
fairies around and we love her long dark
hair while other fairies tend to wear
bright clothing
Vidia easily stands out with her dark
purple outfit as you might have guessed
Vidia is one of the most sarcastic
fairies out there while others tend to
be energetic and genuinely kind Vidya
used to use the words dear and darling
in a condescending manner still she's
good at heart
otherwise she wouldn't be featured as
the main character in the Disney fairy
movies she's the only character that
changed with the plot of the film and
managed to grow her personality into
bold and loving Vidya is known as the
fast-flying fairy she uses the power of
her superfast wings to control whirl
winds and even keep an eye on tornadoes
Vidya can also be found in the actual
Disney Land and she looks just as cool
as she does in Tinkerbell movies Vidya
is voiced by Pamela Adlon who's also
known for her role as Bobby Hill from
king of the hill
fans tend to love her character because
she stands out from the crowd with her
personality and something that she'd be
a perfect addition to the Slytherin
house in Harry Potter
Iridessa if you thought vidya is a
unique character wait until you see
Iridessa she's one of the very few
african-american disney characters and
one of the most talented light fairies
being a light fairy gives her the power
to control everything that has to do
with daylight Iridessa has a very good
sense of humor and she's one of the
smartest fairies around looks-wise
Iridessa has a unique yellow dress
sandals and dark hair that's always
pinned up in a bun this is a real-life
version of Iridessa created by a
cosplayer named Sidonie doesn't she look
just like a fairy were very impressed
with this version and we love her yellow
dress
Iridessa is voiced by Raven Symone who
absolutely adores the character Iridessa
is a perfectionist and she doesn't want
to mess things up did you know that
Raven was just 18 years old when she was
offered the role and by the time they
started working on the fourth movie she
was 24 she said you are definitely able
to see her own facial expressions in the
light fairy and she even stated that
Iridessa does do a lot of things Raven
would also do if she becomes a fairy
while area Dez's power controls the
light
Raven had one of the best powers when
she was voicing her character she was
able to come to work in her pajamas
Tinker Bell we've shown you nine Disney
fairy characters that have all played a
somewhat significant part in the fairy
stories but Tinker Bell also nicknamed
as tink is such an iconic character she
has managed to appear in several other
movies we even give a nickname Tinker
Bell to someone who is petite and bubbly
Tinker Bell is possibly one of the most
recognizable Disney characters she's
fearless sassy and witty and she doesn't
have a problem standing up for herself
she has several superpowers and she's an
expert when it comes to craftsmanship as
her name suggests she can easily upgrade
any gadget and machinery and she's
blessed with the power of super
intelligence apart from the Disney Faire
movies Tinkerbell is most known for her
original role in Peter Pan her animated
character is voiced by Mae Whitman
while her live-action character is
played by Julia Roberts the real-life
Tinkerbell can be found in Disneyland
but did you know that there's a
misconception over who this fairy
character was modeled by many think this
iconic fairy got her looks from Marilyn
Monroe but the truth is she was based on
Margaret Kerry while Margaret is now
almost 90 years old she's still very
proud of the legacy she was able to
leave behind with her iconic fairy
character which Disney fairy superpower
would you have let us know in the
comments for more Disney videos check
out 10 Despicable Me characters in real
life see you next time
[Music]